hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen or
whatever you celebrate her don't
celebrate December today I am watching a
movie that a lot of people consider to
be their favorite Christmas film or like
a Christmas classic I know it's Disney I
know it's Tim Allen I think it just
always looked super cheesy to me and
also something that's just been done a
bunch of times and also I just don't
watch movies I'm trying to make all
these excuses for why I haven't seen it
hi I'm Tamara that's why I'm dressed up
as Judy I think her name is elf I'm not
even dressed up as I just wanted an
excuse to wear these ears this was made
three years after I was born 1994 and
[Music]
that's all I really know
you
[Music]
if you like this movie you're gonna love
the end half of this reaction if you
don't like this movie you're gonna love
the beginning half of this reaction
I stood up really hating this movie and
then halfway through did a complete 180
and started to genuinely enjoy this
movie the movie opens and Tim Allen is
at this work Christmas party and he fun
Lee and light heartedly makes this joke
about how his co-worker is casually
cheating on his significant other huh I
don't know that Tim Allen has ever
actually made me laugh he's just so sick
calming to me and that was like a very
big problem when this movie came out
everyone was like is she gonna hold up
to this like feature-length Disney film
he's just a sitcom actor a lot of people
think you do does dude i Joe especially
in this first part I don't find him fun
at all or funny I don't know that the
movies trying to shoot for her to be
funny but if they are I love him as Buzz
Lightyear everything else it's like I
take it or leave it
Tim comes home on Christmas Eve and
finds his ex-wife and son there so the
Sun can spend Christmas Eve with him
it's very classic 90s like a divorced
parents dynamic your boyfriend Neil was
ugly oh yeah well you're responsible
he's never here why do I always have to
fight then the next scene is them going
to Denny's on Christmas Eve because
they've ruined the dinner so it's bad
they go in in the front room is filled
with a bunch of Asian people did you
know ha ha ha Christmas the back room is
filled with a bunch of single dads and
their children that's really really
really sad like effectively very sad
like when a twin dies
at Denny's his son Charlie asks for
chocolate milk and the waiter says that
they're all out at Denny's his son
Charlie asks for chocolate milk and the
waiter says that they're out and in the
most dejected sad voice Charlie just
goes okay
this kid has two well-off parents that
love him and provide for him he's a
psychiatrist
as a stepfather who probably helps him a
ton but somebody help this kid he's just
a kid in his life it's a nightmare
throughout the Denny's scene which I
will admit was a very well-written very
effective scene he seems to be trying to
do his best I felt bad for him felt bad
for Timmy you're a single dad you're
bound to end up in a situation like this
at some point
any single parent is and you wanted you
know this means they're doing their best
he's not doing his best he's reading
Charlie A Christmas Story and skipping
half and then Charlie asks the question
about it and he rolls his eyes at
Charlie oh my god it's Christmas Eve you
nasty Charlie's asking a bunch of
questions he's not giving him any
answers like how did the reindeer fly
mmm
Red Bull actually No then Charlie here's
Santa on the roof and runs into his
father's room and this happens
that was intentional oh it's an
intentional pose he's like I'm gonna be
in a fat suit for the rest of this movie
I'm gonna look sexy for once
sexy bed pen sexy bed pegs sexy bed
books it's not just plate then he runs
outside and scares Santa off of his roof
killing him
it just doesn't like wound him doesn't
talk him into retirement he kills Santa
yes I didn't know that good Santa Falls
and as he's gliding off of the roof this
snow light comes with him in a sheet
because they're filming a minister in LA
I think lose all of the snow is super
fake especially now that I live in
Chicago where there's real snow from
California I know the difference you
guys I know the difference between
actual frozen water and plastic okay
don't think that I don't I do then a
reindeer farts
[Laughter]
tim is the worst throughout all of this
he's grumbling about it he's like this
is stupid
his son is like why do you think
everything is he was stupid he said fine
fine no I didn't mean that we'll do it
we'll do it
he's like grumbling as he's putting on
this outfit a kid sees him in the first
house he goes into and asked us why his
clothes are so baggy and Santa really
sassily goes Sansa swatching his
saturated fat so they finished
delivering presents to every child in
the entire world okay and a small child
reached them in the North Pole
thank you creepy small child thank you
still wasn't really getting it again
hasn't seen it okay so he's the new
Santa cool remember when I said that I
know the difference between snow when
plastic earlier about it that's all I
got rolling around up here so he's in
the Santa workshop and he picks up a
tool belt and he puts it up to him like
he's gonna put it on he's like oh what a
fun call to his show do you get it cuz
he's if you don't get it just too smart
for the room such a blast so he's
turning into sampling crepe and he
obviously has to improve from being this
likable jerk to this likable a hero of
Santa and they'd say it's like Scrooge
which I loved I didn't love this bill I
didn't think it was fun enough to
warrant the Glee character being such a
journey loved Scrooge cue the thumbs
down a hook this video no it was already
there yeah I have to get over my
personal dislike of terrible people
characters so I'm giving it a chance he
wakes up back in his bed Charlie still
remembers everything he thinks it's a
dream they spend the next four scenes
trying to convince Charlie that it
didn't actually happen that Charlie's a
crazy kid and then he starts gaining
weight and his hair turns white and he's
like
I had so much more fun with Tim Allen as
a bigger man
he was funnier he was way more likable
and I guess that's just the Santa Claus
effect you know and this is crazy guys
this is gonna sound nuts I don't like
I'm like I'm okay I don't like unlikable
characters I ain't crazy I know his
coworkers though are dicks
he shows up to work he only has sweats
that fit him and they're like wow what
happened you're wait I should uh I
thought your mom that's what and then
she
I'm sitting alive then Tim goes to the
doctor to see what's wrong still doesn't
really think he's Santa and he says I've
gained 45 pounds in a week the mom and
the boyfriends Neil try to take Charlie
from his father because they only see
this kid who says that his dad is Santa
Claus and then they see the dad turning
into Santa Claus thinking that he's
manipulating this kids who the most
extreme and that's pretty terrifying to
think like if he wasn't Santa Claus and
he was just like gaining all this weight
and dyeing his hair white and growing a
beard that's nuts and then the dad
realizes his full potential as Santa
somebody steals Charlie for this epic
Christmas adventure and the mom walks
out and the worst line read I maybe ever
heard goes
Charlie and dad go out again it's way
better than last year and I could grease
eateries oh he's so much nicer than last
year oh I love this
I feel so Christmassy now actual things
that I wrote Santa gets arrested for
kidnapping and then Breaking and
Entering and then L save him obviously
this is Christmas bitches I think that
terribly CGI'd elves are gonna fly
through the air and save Santa from
prison get some respect on those lips
okay so Santa's saved then they return
Charlie to the mom and Santa's like you
know you got to say to your mom now I'm
gonna go finish the gifts now and and
then Charlie says I love you Santa and
he's saying that to his father and to
Santa at the same time listen every
kid's dream and I said oh I'm
crying at the Santa Claus movie then the
mom and Neal get the gifts they never
got his children and Santa cos it's them
and I'm like okay Kim I see you now I
see you didn't see you in the beginning
of the movie but I you know some jolly
ass guys I don't know if it's the
unlikable character trait that just
feels very like a tease to me smade in
the early 90s but it felt oh whoa he
wasn't written well I don't think in the
beginning not saying this is a brilliant
script in the end half either but it's
at least enjoyable to watch this man
turn in Santa Claus versus
versus this man just be a dick to ask it
and like begrudgingly delivered gifts to
you know it just it wasn't enjoyable and
it was enjoyable and it was cheesy as
hell I liked it
made me cry I think that all Christmas
movies should make you cry a little bit
at the end you know what I mean next
week I'm watching eight crazy nights
can't wait to cry that one bah
oh I'm just a cat and my life is a
nightmare
sorry sorry sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
you